special edition of pft pm joining us now
the 2016 nfl mvp
quarterback the atlanta falcons since
2008 is matt ryan matt hello how are you
i'm doing great mike thanks for having
me on wait i tell you what this is a new
world that we're
existing in where we do these video
conferences the first time i've done one
of these
where the guy i'm talking to is at his
press conference spot
with the background and everything i
feel like i'm having an exclusive press
conference with matt ryan today
one one-on-one man this is uh this is
special for you
it's weird for me too you know i've been
doing these kind of zoom interviews
uh all off season and been on my
computer and a setup in the house but
i'm in the facility today so we've got
great lighting you know an official
setup uh feels you know much more
professional how different is the
facility now that you've been back there
for the first time since the world
turned upside down
yeah it's definitely it's definitely
different uh we're we're lucky
you know that that we've got a pretty
we've got a lot of space
and uh you know a massive setup for us
to be able to kind of space out and make
sure that we
uh are kind of up to up to coat on all
of the protocols
we have these kind of town homes that uh
we stay in during
uh training camp that are built right
behind our facility uh which we're able
to use as our locker room right now we
each have our in
you know our own individual bathroom and
bed and
changing area and all that kind of stuff
with doors so we're uniquely
you know built to kind of handle this
and uh our staff here has done an
amazing job of
of trying to make it as safe as possible
for everybody and i appreciate them
doing that
you know at some point though games are
going to be played players go home
to and from and they'll be traveling
we've seen a lot of guys so far more
than i thought
opt out for the season what advice would
you give to a teammate that's wrestling
with that question of whether or not to
just press pause on his career
for 2020 well i think everybody's
circumstances are different
right and and you know you have to do
what's best for yourself
and and for your family and your loved
ones around you and
and i think that uh you know if if
you're around people who are at risk you
know i'd encourage you to to really
think long and hard about it but
uh for me specifically i feel like i'm
in a situation where
you know my day-to-day is is is not
surrounded by people
who are at high risk and we're able to
kind of uh
you know bubble our little world and and
make sure that you know we're we're
being as safe as possible so i feel
comfortable
uh you know coming in and and getting
ready to to start this season
for the first time since your last year
at boston college no pre-season games
how different
will this year be for you than all of
your other nfl seasons as you prepare
for week one without the benefit of
going through the motions even if you
don't play in a preseason game you go
through the motions you go to the locker
room
you get your uniform on you you get used
to how it's going to be how different
will it be
without that this year yeah i think
you know it will be different i i you
know i kind of like the
the preseason games to be able to get
out there and knock off some of that
you know rust that you have to be able
to you know
go go through it like you said go
through your routine make sure that
you know you're doing the things you
need to do and you kind of have things
ironed out we're not
going to have that luxury uh but you
know i think dan is is putting together
dan quinn is putting together a really
good schedule for us
to try and you know simulate as much as
we can on our own
you know what that experience is going
to be like and you know i think it's
more important for a guy like me i'm in
year 13 i
i think it's you know it's it's going to
be easier for a guy like myself
having been through so many different
situations so many years so many
you know games played and feeling
comfortable in those but for our rookies
and for our young guys who have not had
that experience you know i think
we've got to help them out as much as we
can and uh try and make them
feel as comfortable as possible because
you know when when we kick it off
against seattle week one
you know that that game is just as
important as week 17 and uh it means
just as much
you know this season is going to present
plenty of advantages and disadvantages
but it's got to be an advantage
to have a starting quarterback with the
same team not changing teams like a tom
brady in tampa but you're with the same
team you've been there
it's got to make it so much easier to
get ready for the season without the
benefit of a pre-season
i'd like to think so you know i i think
having the same coordinator
a lot of continuity within the building
all of those things
make going through experiences like this
that are unique
uh it makes it easier because you know
you have that
you know you have that foundation built
with with these guys
where you understand uh how to work with
each other and
you know i think that's going to benefit
us i really hope it benefits us
uh and it gives us some kind of
advantage
with tom brady now in tampa with
everything the saints have done the last
three years so much talk about new
orleans and tampa new orleans and tampa
do you get sick of that or do you kind
of like it you kind of like being able
to stay off radar nobody's really
focused on the falcons
and we can just go about our business
and maybe surprise some people when
september rolls around
yeah i think you know i think it's uh
it's one of those things
the perspective i always have is you
know who cares about everybody else we
have to
you know we have to take care of our own
business and we have to you know put in
the work on the day-to-day to give
ourselves a chance to be able to compete
week in and week out and so
you know it doesn't bother me that that
other people are talked about that's
kind of been the case you know at
different times throughout my career and
uh we've been successful during those
times so you know i don't i don't worry
about it too much and
you know try and you know make sure
we're focused on you know taking care of
our own business
you guys finished strong last year six
and two down the stretch and from time
to time we've seen that carry over for
teams
into the next year how much of what you
did the final eight games of 2019 do you
believe can carry over
and set the tone this season
well i think a lot of it can you know i
think because there is so much
continuity
i think uh you know sometimes when you
have a finish like that but there's
changes
uh that momentum and and and that you
know feeling that you had kind of goes
away but
i really feel like you know with raheem
morris kind of stepping in
in the second half of the season helping
out with defense and now him being the
coordinator
dirk cutter and year two dan quinn
really comfortable in his role
of of kind of facilitating everything um
you know i i just feel like we're in a
good spot and i feel like there's tons
of continuity with the players
and there's an understanding of of what
it takes to be successful particularly
for our young guys we had tons of young
guys who were playing late in the season
last year
uh and even though we weren't in the mix
for the playoffs you have to learn how
to win in this league
and and i think that experience of of
learning what it takes how to finish out
games how to find ways to
win when it's not perfect uh those are
the things that will pay dividends for
us this season
matt one area where there isn't
continuity is it running back and if
todd burley is healthy
arguably a significant upgrade how
different will the offense be
if we get a healthy todd very girly on
the field for the falcons
very different i think you know he's
been one of the most dynamic players
when he's on the field in our league and
and and certainly a game changer
and you know i i had the opportunity to
to work out with him a little bit this
offseason
and spend just a little bit of time with
him uh he seems to be in a really good
you know really good place i mean he
looked great on the field and you know
has has been
working extremely hard to get himself in
position to you know to
to be ready to go and so i'm excited we
haven't because
you know i think he adds a lot to what
we can do
tom brady turns 43 next week drew brees
is 41. you're 35.
how much longer is matt ryan going to
play in the nfl
uh you know i'd like to chase those guys
i feel good my you know my body feels
good
i'm i'm still as excited about this as
ever i still feel like i'm playing
um you know really good football and i
feel like my best is still in front of
me and so
i'll take it you know one day at a time
for sure but
i'm doing everything i can to ensure
that you know i can play as long as i
can go
and so um you know i'm excited about
that hopefully i can
you know be 43 and sitting here having
the same interview with you about being
excited for an upcoming season
well and that's one of the realities to
a plan until you're 43 sometimes this
the team decides to go in a different
direction before the quarterback decides
to
exit the sport and we've seen it with
tom brady we've seen it with peyton
manning we may see it with aaron rodgers
have you entertained that possibility
that maybe you get to a point where you
want to keep playing
and it's going to have to be with a
different team i
you know i'll get there when i get there
at this point you know i've i've
i haven't you know i haven't had that
feeling i haven't had that come up or
that situation in front of me but you
know
everybody everybody's career arc is
different right and and everybody's
career goes in different directions and
so one of the things i think
you know i've learned along the way is
to you know worry about today worry
about this year and this season and then
you know worry about the next one next
year and go from there so
uh we'll cross that bridge if and when
we get there you know a lot of people
think professional athletes don't
get motivated by different snubs and
omissions especially guys who've been
around for a decade or longer
did it bug you that you weren't on that
nfl top 100 list
i mean i don't that kind of stuff
doesn't you know change my day
right like it's it's never been for me
bulletin board material or anything like
that um
i know what i can do you know i know
what i'm capable of doing
uh and i feel like you know every week i
give our team a great chance to win
and you know if we get the ball late in
the game i know i have what it takes to
to finish it out so i don't worry about
that stuff
i just focus on trying to do the job the
best i can and matt you're here with us
today on behalf of the gatorade athlete
of the year program tell us more about
that and where we can find out even more
about the program
yeah i'm excited you know i got to meet
uh eric gilbert back
in december when he was named the 2019 i
guess at that point uh
gatorade football player of the year but
he's the 2020 male athlete of the year
which is
the most prestigious high school award
there is i'm fired up for him he's going
to be a great player at lsu
i got to meet him in december and he
certainly looks the part man i was
impressed with
uh with his setup he is uh he's going to
be a great player so i'm excited for him
congratulations to him
uh and everybody can find more
information on on himself and
the other winners uh at gatorade all
right hey i gotta let you go one last
question though on the way out and i've
i've seen this question posed to others
in the past and the answer can't be both
hall of fame bust or super bowl ring
which one
oh man uh
you know right now it's super bowl ring
is what's motivating me to get out of
bed
right it's it's about winning that and
so uh
hopefully one will go with the other but
if i had to take one i'd take the super
bowl ring right now all right matt hey
we appreciate some of your time
and all the best this season stay safe
and thanks everyone for joining us for
this one day wednesday edition of pftp
i'm matt we hope to talk to you again
real soon
thanks mike hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports